-How is the fam, by the way?
-The fam is good.
It's summer.
They're just chilling out.
-I got to see them randomly on
the street with your husband,
and I saw them.
They're very cute.
How old are they now?
-They're 11. They're twins.
-Are they 11?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-We're spending time.
It's a cool age, 11.
-It's happening fast.
-Your girls are how old?
-8 and 7.
-Yeah, so it's like -- it's
a fun age, where you don't
have to really micromanage them
all of the time.
And you can sort of hang out
and coexist with them, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Correct.
-Ish?
-That's exactly right.
Yeah, I can coexist.
-They're watching content.
Gideon is a big gamer.
He loves "Minecraft."
-Roblox?
-He likes the Roblox alright.
Harper is into horror movies.
-See, that's --
Isn't it interesting?
They're twins.
-Yeah.
-You feed them the same food.
-You read them the same book.
-Raise them gender neutral.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly, and here they are.
Two different human beings.
-Totally different.
What do you say to a girl who
wants to watch horror movies?
Like, do you say
"absolutely not"?
Because then she wants to
watch them more.
She's just seen "It" now. Scary.
-No.
I can't even watch the trailer
for "It."
[ Laughter ]
-She binge-watched
"Stranger Things."
So, she's, like -- not
horror-horror, but still scary.
-It's up there.
-And so she keeps asking me,
"Papa, what is the scariest
movie that you've ever seen?"
And I know where this is going
'cause I -- I said,
"I'm not going to tell you
the scariest movie"
'cause she's going to
want to watch that."
-Of course.
-"Papa, what's the --
Please tell me the scariest
movie you've ever seen."
I said, "The Shining."
[ Audience murmurs ]
So she says,
"Can I watch 'The Shining?'"
[ Laughter ]
-Of course.
-And I said "No, you can't watch
'The Shining.'
'The Shining' is really
psychologically terrifying."
-Yeah.
-And so, she just kept asking
and persisting, and so we
watched "The Shining" last week.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, what a beautiful family.
Father-daughter moment.
-I don't know
if it was a good call.
But I --
And it is still really scary.
-It is, right?
-Jack Nicholson.
Super freaky, bloody elevator.
-Oh, the blood flows
through the hall
and the twin on the tricycle.
-The girls staring. Scary.
And she was like -- I said,
"So, what'd you think?"
She said,
"I'm mildly disappointed."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm mildly disappointed"?
-"I'm a bit disappointed."
-I love that she said that.
-"Well, why?"
She said, "That was the scariest
movie you've ever seen?"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "It's not scary like
2022 scary."
-Yeah, it's not jump-scare,
yeah.
-And she was like,
"Yeah, it wasn't that scary."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! Good for her.
-And she has slept in our bed
for like the last four nights.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah, reality, reality.
It was a little scary,
wasn't it?
-I think it was a little scarier
than she thought.
-I want to talk to you
about something
you started about a year ago.
This thing is called
"Wondercade."
-"Wondercade," yeah.
-And I think it's a great word.
If you go to wondercade.com,
it's free.
It's a newsletter.
-Mm-hmm.
-Weekly?
-Weekly.
-Weekly newsletter.
-"Wondercade Wednesdays."
Just happened today.
-Yeah.
Explain to people what
Wondercade is
and why did you start this?
I love that you did it.
-I'm old enough now, and I have
a lot of varied weird interests
of like magic and circus and
traveling and I like mixology.
My husband is an actor as well
as a chef.
And so we talk a lot of things.
I host Tony awards and say like,
"Come see Broadway shows."
So I feel like I have
some things to talk about
in the entertainment world.
And so I thought it would be fun
to do sort of
a weekly missive
of random things.
So I came up with "wonder,"
like "wonder" and "wonderful,"
and "cade,"
like "arcade" or "cavalcade."
And I put them together,
"Wondercade,"
because the URL was available.
[ Laughter ]
So I own the site.
So you go to wondercade.com,
you put in your e-mail.
That's it.
That's the whole thing.
-You invented the word
"Wondercade."
-"Wondercade."
-It sounds like a word I know.
-Thank you.
-It's fantastic, well done.
-And now more people know it.
And every Wednesday,
it's just stuff.
Like, I'll teach how to
make a Negroni.
The one that just came out was
all about farmers market.
David went with Michael Anthony,
who's an amazing chef.
From Gramercy Tavern. And they
went to a farmers market.
And then they sort of explain
when you go to a farmers market
what you should look for
and some recipes on that.
It ends with a puzzle.
It's kind of, like, a fun weekly
thing, you know.
-I love this. "Wondercade,"
everyone check it out.
If you go there,
just type your e-mail in.
You get a fun e-mail.
You go, "Oh, this is awesome."
I love it.
-Thank you.
Very cool that
you mentioned that.
I appreciate that.
-Oh, please. I'm on.
I'm signed up. I get it.
I love it.
I want to talk about "Uncoupled"
because I'm very excited
about this.
I love a good show,
and I love -- I do.
And I love who's behind it.
Can you tell everyone
who's behind the show?
-Sure, Darren Star
is the co-creator.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Sex and the City."
-"Emily in Paris."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I mean, come on!
That's up my alley, man.
I love that.
-They're only half-hour
episodes.
They come out on Fridays.
There's eight of them.
It's about -- My character,
Michael,
is in a 17-year relationship
with his partner, Colin.
And Michael thinks everything is
going well.
And on his 50th birthday --
not Michael's, but Colin's --
Michael's throwing him
a surprise party.
And just as he's about to open
the door at this big event space
with hundreds of people waiting,
Colin says, "I've taken all
my stuff and I've left
and we're no longer together."
And then, "Surprise!"
[ Laughter ]
-And then the door opens, "Hi!"
-Big party.
So the whole series is like
a breakup show of what happens
when you've been sort of sucker
punched with terrible news
and you're single again
in New York City.
So it's a comedy.
[ Laughter ]
-There are great jokes in there.
-But it's sort of -- I mean,
it is Darren Star, so it's got
real-estate agents, so it's got
some New York, you know,
real-estate porn kind of vibe.
[ Laughter ]
The city is a character
within it,
which I think
you can appreciate.
It's got a nice feel.
-Real-estate porn.
It does. If you know Darren Star
or know any of those shows,
it's just some good acting.
There's some good puzzles
in there, conundrums,
and life lessons,
but it's also fun.
-Some pithy conversation.
-Pithy is a very good word.
-And then you kind of
shed a tear.
I'm really proud of it. It's
tonally an interesting show.
But breakups are -- by design --
-And it all comes out Friday?
-Yeah, all Friday.
-So you can binge-watch
the whole thing?
-Breakups aren't always sad.
You know?
There's funny things that happen
in life through sadness.
-Yes, through your sadness,
breakups become fun.
-Right, and I thought making
a gay show on Netflix
about a gay relationship that's
ending would be very niche.
Right? Only for like gay men of
a certain age.
And it turns out that breakups
are pretty universal
and pretty relatable.
You know what I mean?
-Oh, yeah, trust me. Yeah.
We just had a thing of
why I'm single on our show.
Yeah, everyone can relate to
this all.
It's very, very good.
Very funny.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Neil Patrick Harris
in "Uncoupled."
Take a look at this.
-Isn't it great?
I don't even care that we're
the oldest gays in the club.
No, honey, you keep dancing.
We have just as much right
to be here as --
-I think that's Colin.
-Well, first of all,
you look fantastic.
-You really do. So hot.
It's not him. Oh, thank God.
-I'm not even sure if I'm happy
or not that that wasn't him.
I need a drink.
-Mikey, there's only one way
you're going to move on
from this.
-Yeah, it's been one whole week.
Enough with the wallowing.
-Sorry.
I just think if you want to
start feeling better,
you got to pop your Colin cherry
and get laid.
-So eloquent.
Sadly, I don't disagree.
-So glad to know that you're
both on the same page
about what's best for me.
Three vodka sodas, please.
-What do you guys want?
[ Laughter ]
-Very nice.
"What do you guys want?"
Neil Patrick Harris, everybody.
"Uncoupled" premieres
this Friday on Netflix.
Cara Delevingne joins us
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.